jb oui
du rugby
un court métrage pour convaincre les
filles de se lancer dans le monde de
l'ovalie
l'idée de la section féminine du rugby
club de montigny le bretonneux l'équipe
qui compte une vingtaine d'adhérentes a
travaillé sur ce projet pendant plus de
six mois avant de lancer la vidéo mois
d'août sur internet
j'ai proposé le projet à l'équipe qui
l'a accepté et on a décidé de le faire
de façon commune
on a écrit le scénario ensemble et après
ben tout s'est mis en place petit à
petit l'organisation ça on a vraiment
voulu tout faire ensemble sauf le côté
technique parce que c'est mon métier
du coup c'est plus facile mais c'est un
projet complet de quoi on a rigolé on a
refait plusieurs fois les prises parce
que des fois c'était raté voilà mais
c'est des bons moments et sasso de
l'équipe baptisée osé la différence
cette campagne 2.0 a également pour but
de briser les clichés sur le rugby
féminin un sport qui peine à s'imposer
auprès des filles sur les 400 mille
licenciés de l'hexagone
les rugbywomen ne représente que 3% des
joueurs et a plein de filles elles ont
pas envie d'avoir des bleus un coquard
des coups de crampons prince est vrai
que des fois quand on est un peu
coquette qu'on doit mettre des jupes
parler travailler c'est un peu difficile
peu avec les coups de crampons sur les
gens de tout mais je pense que oui on as
a attiré quelques fictions nerfs au
moins essayer même si leur paie pas quoi
par exemple au forum d assaut ou dans
notre quotidien toutes les filles vous
le dis on est souvent confronté aux gens
qui nous disent ah bon mais pourtant
t'as pas l'air d'une boue rhinois voilà
quoi t'es pas un garçon manqué ils ont
tous ces clichés comme quoi le rugby
c'est un sport vraiment pour une fille
que c'est fois de garçon manqué faut
être gros sa voix alors que pas du tout
faits gabarits sont fait pour le rugby
depuis son lancement la vidéo a été
visionnée plus de 1800 fois sur internet
les joueuses de montigné attend
désormais les possibles nouvelles
recrues sur le terrain expérimenté ou
comme moi débutante
il ya forcément une place pour vous
alors venez défier les clichés projet
nous rejoignez nous
rejoignez nous